[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es ein
leckeres hauptgericht von mir und zu
machen wir kebab im ofen mit kartoffeln
und paprika einer meiner lieblings
speisen also auch außerhalb von avatar
ich mache auch immer gleich eine große
menge damit ich am nächsten tag auch
davon essen kann und falls ja auch fans
anderer gemüsesorten seid dann könnt ihr
das gerne noch mit reinigen aber ich
sage euch jetzt zuallererst die zutaten
zuallererst kümmern wir uns um das
fleisch und dafür benötigen wir inder
hackfleisch zwiebeln die habe ich
bereits gefallen gehackt außerdem etwas
paniermehl und an gewürzen salz pfeffer
paprika flocken sind und gemahlenen
gummi
jetzt gehen wir einfach alle zutaten in
eine schüssel und verkneten das richtig
gut mit den händen
[Musik]
mein fleisch habe ich jetzt gut
durchgeknetet und jetzt geht's ans form
ich habe mir hier schon mein backbleche
vorbereitet haben sagt und da habe ich
einfach nur ein backpapier draufgelegt
das müsst ihr nicht extra fetten denn
unser hackfleisch beinhaltet ja schon
genug wird und jetzt nehme ich mir immer
so eine golfball größe und form das dann
oval
[Musik]
nachdem wir das fleisch nun muss ford
haben geben wir in den vorgeheizten
backofen bei 200 grad ober und
unterhitze und dann braucht ihr so 15
bis 20 minuten wichtig ist nämlich dass
das ganze überhaupt vor backen denn dann
behält ist die form und wird auch noch
richtig schön knusprig während das
fleisch ist im ofen gar zeige ich euch
schon mal die zutaten für unsere soße
denn die können wir schon mal
vorbereiten also wir benötigen etwas
tomatenmark außerdem paprika mark
neutrales öl etwas salz und etwas wasser
in einem ausreichend großen topf fällt
sich jetzt erst mal das öl und dann
nämlich tomaten und paprika marx hinzu
und rüste es darin ungefähr eine minute
an
[Musik]
und jetzt lassen wir das ganze mit dem
wasser ab
[Musik]
jetzt gehen wir das salz mit hinzu und
rühren das noch mal gut und wenn die
klümpchen alle aufgelösten dem was er
dann ist die soße auch schon fertig und
die soße kommt jetzt bis zur
weiterverarbeitung an die seite sowieso
selbst vorbereitet ist fleisch ist im
ofen ist auch noch fünf minuten sehe ich
gerade und jetzt kümmern wir uns um das
gemüse und zwar nehme ich heute
kartoffeln und eine rote paprika ihr
könnt natürlich auch gerne irgendwas
anderes nehmen möhren tomaten auberginen
ist auch gern und maschine genommen aber
haben sie mag in aubergine als didier
aber okay com heute sind wir mit ihm
haben sei deswegen werde ich jetzt
zuallererst die kartoffeln stehen und
dann den einzeln die meter große
scheiben schneiden
[Musik]
kartoffeln und paprika will klein
geschnitten und das fleisch ist auch
schon aus dem ofen für mich rausgeholt
und jetzt brauchen wir eine auflaufform
ich nehme hier die rechteckige ihr könnt
doch gerne eine runde nehme das alles so
rund aneinanderreihen ist finde ich auch
super schön aber ich habe mich jetzt für
die entschieden und jetzt sollte ich das
einfach hier ein und die reihenfolge ist
egal also ob ihr da zwei
kartoffelscheiben oder mal drei nimmt
macht das ganze ihr möchtet hauptsache
es passt am ende alles in die form
[Musik]
nachdem ihr gemüse und fleisch
einsortiert hat in eure auflaufform gebt
ihr anschließend die tomatensoße darüber
[Musik]
ich mach das mal so dass die kartoffeln
noch ein stückchen an der oberfläche zu
sehen sind dann ist es für mich genau
perfekt und jetzt gebe ich das zurück in
den ofen der immer noch heiß ist bei 200
grad für ungefähr 35 bis 40 minuten als
beilage gibt es bei mir jetzt typisch
türkischen reis und von denen mit denen
kleinen schaden also schädigen nudeln
und wir müssen das immer gerne mit einem
glas ab oder einer tasse
ich schreibe euch aber sonst auch gerne
die gramm zahl in der infobox frei zu
euch dann einfach sicherer seit für den
menge an fleisch und gemüse habe ich
jetzt hier zweieinhalb tasten reich und
die doppelte menge wasser ich zeige euch
jetzt aber ganz genau weil die zutaten
also hier habe ich den risen 2 espace
martin reis außerdem cherry das sind
diese jodeln neutrales öl ein wenig
butter salz und wasser damit der reifen
macht dem kochen nicht so klebt der
eingelegt in wasser für eine halbe
stunde
aber ich habe gemerkt dass man sich den
schritt sparen kann auch wenn es ganz
viel mit mir schimpfen und dann geht ihr
das geht auch nicht also ich wollte mir
das in dem reis liegt das ist jetzt in
dijon was marty reißt aber den gebe ich
einfach in ein sieb und spüre dass dann
ungefähr fünf minuten am waschbecken
außen dass die ganze stärke verschwunden
und beklebt überhaupt nächste ist total
schön locker und das machen wir jetzt
eben
den reis habe ich jetzt unter fließendem
wasser solange abgespült bis das wasser
unten klar wieder rauskam
das ist zwar nicht mehr trüben und dann
ist es genau richtig jetzt machen wir
aber erstmal weiter mit unseren nudeln
also mit den schädel und ich gebe dafür
zu allererstes öl meint ob und dann
werden die sharia darin goldbraun
gebraten
nachdem die nudeln goldbraun gebraten
wurden müssten wir noch ungefähr eine
minute langen reis darin an und dann
wird das ganze abgelöscht
[Musik]
jetzt gehen wir noch salz hinzu und
lassen das ganze einmal aufkochen
sobald das wasser dann aufkocht gehen
wir den deckel drüber und ganz wichtig
schalten den herd runter schalte zum
beispiel neun stufen haben nimmt die
stufe 2 und so weiter also so dass es
dann richtig langsam garen kam so ihr
lieben meint immer bist fertig habe ich
gerade aus dem ofen holen das duftende
verfügten und noch hier ausdampfen und
jetzt ist auch der reis fertig und da
geben wir jetzt nur noch die butter
fahren und lassen es in der rest hitze
schmelzen ich mache das auch nicht immer
aber man hat dann immer in diesen
leckeren buttergeschmack dabei
[Musik]
und so lecker kann ein star menü sein
also richtig türkische küche ihr habt
ein leckeres hauptgericht mit fleisch
und gemüse und soße mit dabei und
leckerer ist es dafür nie fehlbar und
außerdem habe ich hier diesen salat
vorbereitet hierzu kann ich mich ganz
schön was sagen das ist einfach nur
salat mit all den zutaten er am liebsten
mögen und als dressing habe ich ganz
einfach neutrales öl ein wenig
granatapfel sirup und so mack und salz
genommen ich schreibe euch alles genau
unten in die infobox wie immer übrigens
wie auch alle anderen zutaten und ich
serviere immer ganz gerne noch etwas
naturjoghurt dazu ihr könnt ihr gerne
mehr fett arm nehmen und dem seit sich
auch nicht extra denn wir haben ja schon
genug salz im essen jetzt wünsche ich
euch einen guten appetit
ich freue mich wenn ihr meinen kanal
abonniert damit ihr keines meiner videos
verpasst und dann sehen wir unsere
übermorgen wieder zu meinem nächsten mal
dann rezept
[Musik]
heute geht so richtig türkisch zu merke
ich gerade so richtig typisch türkische
küche kann sehr komisch ja vielleicht ja
sommer saniert und und fleischwaren
[Musik]